hello everyone and welcome to yet
another interesting live session on the
series of sessions related to data
analysis in python
this video will be analyzing and
visualizing the united states
unemployment data set from 1948 to 2021.
this data has been collected from the
united states bureau of labor statistics
the data contains the monthly
unemployment rate from 1948 to 2021.
the file also contains information on
subsets of the population that includes
based on age ranges from 16 years of age
to 55 years of age and above
and it also has information about
unemployment rates for men as well as
women
now let me go ahead and show you the
data set first
so on the screens you can see the
unemployment rate data
let me just
adjust the
column headers
so you
know the different columns that we have
okay
if you see the first column is of date
so it starts from
1st of january
1948
till we have data
till november 2021
okay
so go to the top
then we have the overall unemployment
rate
the next column we have is the overall
unemployment rate for men
over these years then we have the
overall unemployment rate for each of
the months starting from 1948 to 2021
for women
next
we have the different age groups so
unemployment rate for the younger people
16 to 17 years of age then we have
between
18 to 19 then 20 to 24 24 to 34.
this is actually 25 to 34 then 35 to 44
45 to 54 then the last column is 55 and
above
all right so we are going to use this
data set
and
we'll be analyzing for three specific
periods between
1980
to 1990 and then
we'll focus on the great recession of
2010
and we'll also be analyzing the
post-covet data
so to give you a context the early
1980s recession was an economic
recession that affected much of the
world between the start of 1980 and
early 1983.
so it was one of the severe recessions
since world war ii
a key reason for the recession was the
1979 energy crisis
mostly caused by the iranian revolution
which caused a disruption in the global
oil supply
so that saw the oil prices rising softly
in 1979 and early 1980
then we'll focus on the second period
which is the great economic recession
that refers to the economic downturn
from 2007 to 2009
after the boasting of the united states
housing bubble and the global financial
crisis
so the great recession was the most
severe economic recession in the united
states since the great depression of the
1930s
and finally we'll focus on
and analyze data of 2020 when the world
was hit by the global corona virus
pandemic so the pandemic did not only
impact the human lives but it also shook
the economy and job market of infected
countries
so let's head over to our jupiter
notebook and we'll start with our demo
session with importing this data set
for that if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
i'm going to import the
necessary libraries first
so i'll start with
import
numpy or numpy as np
and then i'll have
import
pandas as pd
and then
i'll
import matplotlib
dot
pi plot
as
plt
next i am going to
import cbon
as sns
followed by i'll say percentage
matplotlib
inline
okay
so this is the notebook that i'm going
to use if i scroll down you would see
some of the cells already filled i will
come to this later i just wanted to make
sure that we have
enough time to explore this data set and
try saving some time writing the same
lines of code again and again
okay
so let's go ahead and import all the
necessary libraries i'll hit shift enter
now you can see we have successfully
imported all the necessary libraries the
next step is to
load the data set so i'll give a comment
load the data set
so
i'll store my data set
by converting it into a data frame
with a variable called
an emp which basically stands for
unemployed
so i'll use the function read underscore
csv because the data set that we have or
that we looked at was a csv data set
after that within quotations i need to
pass in the
file location
so let me just go ahead and copy the
file location
just click on this
and here we'll copy this file location
and i'll paste it
i'll click here and i'll paste the
location that we just copied make sure
we have another
backslash otherwise it won't read on a
windows system
i'm using a windows system here
all right
after that i'm going to give
the file name
along with the extension of the file
that is csv
here
i am going to give the
file name which is unemployment
score rate underscore
data.csv actually
data
dot csv
okay this looks fine
and
to print the
first five rows of the data frame let me
just use the head function
so i'll say unemployment dot head
let's run it
okay so here you can see the output
below so we have the first five rows
from the data frame it has all the
columns starting from the date column
till the last column which is
unemployment rate for 55 years and above
great
now in the next
cell let's check
the
data types of each of the columns that
we saw
and the normal values as well as the
memory usages
so for that i'm going to say
unemployment dot
info
hit shift enter
you can see here
i have different column names on the top
you can see there are total 887 entries
as in there are total 887 rows in my
data frame
starting from 0 to 886 we have the
different columns
the normal count
and you have the data type here and at
the bottom you can see the memory it is
using
cool
next
we need to convert
the
date column that is the first column
into
date format or
date time format for that
we need to
make some changes
so i will say
unemployment which is my data frame name
within
where brackets i'll see my column name
that is date equal to
pd dot
to underscore
date time
which is the function
and i will say
unemployment and i'll pass in my column
that is date
next let's use the
describe function i'll say unemployment
dot describe to get some statistical
outputs
there you go
so here you can see the count for each
of the
columns that is 887 and then for each of
the columns we have the minimum
value which means
the overall unemployment rate
starting from 1948 to 2021 in the united
states has been
around 5.7
percent
and then
if you check for
the unemployment rate for men the
maximum it has touched is 13.3 percent i
believe this is
during the covet pandemic
and the lowest is 1.9 percent
again if you check for women the highest
unemployment rate in women
has touched
15.7 percent which is again during the
kovid pandemic
and then we have
the unemployment rate for the
age groups now if you see the maximum
value for the different age groups you
find
that
there are more unemployed people between
16 to 17 years of age that is the
younger population are the ones who are
mostly hit by the unemployment in the
united states
okay
now moving ahead
for that i just wanted to
call it out again that historically what
we see is that six percent of women on
an
average
have been unemployed as compared to five
point
six percent of men
now let's visualize the overall
unemployment rate so here we are going
to create our first visualization now
and that would be a line chart
so i'll say
plt dot
figure
within square brackets i'll write
figure
size
let's say we'll give the figure size as
15 comma 5
okay
next
i'm going to say
plt dot plot to plot my
line chart or line graph
then i'll pass in my
data frame that is unemployment
i'll call my
date
and then we'll have
employment rate column so again i'll
pass in my
data frame name within square brackets
i'll say
on rate
if you see the
first column here this is the
unemployment rate that is the overall
unemployment rate
let's go ahead and run this
it will plot
this line chart for us
now what you see is
there are three instances of high
unemployment in the united states
one is between
1980 to
1985 you can see there is a clear spike
and then
the second instance is between
2010 to 2015 there's again a clear spike
at the maximum spike in
the unemployment in the united states is
after 2020 that is the time when the
world was hit by covet pandemic
cool so we'll be focusing on
these
regions or these
time periods specifically in our
analysis
now next
we want to find the unemployment rate
for women
so i'll just give a comment unemployment
rate for
women
that i'll again say plt dot
figure
within brackets i'll say
figure
size
to be
equal to
15 comma 5
and then i'm going to use the c bond
library and the
sns
abbreviation
so i'll say sns dot
i'll say line plot
to plot my line
graph
within brackets i'll say
data
equal to my data frame name that is
unemployment
comma
in the x axis i want the date column
in the y axis i want the
on rate underscore women column to
give me the unemployment rate for women
starting from 1948 to
2021
and then you can also use
a color
let's say i use color equal to red
now
we'll run this
and let's see the output
cool you can see here the total
unemployment rate of women
starting from 1948 till 2020 one
and again you can see there are clear
spikes around these regions where the
world
even the united states economy was hit
by a crisis
similarly let me just copy this
and we'll now check
the unemployment rate for men
that is the overall unemployment rate
i'll just edit this
data remains the same my x
axis remains the same in the y axis i
will say
unrate
underscore men that is
this column okay
and maybe we can change the color to
let's say
blue
now let us run it
and here you can see
for
men during the covet pandemic
the unemployment rate for
men reach almost
over 13 percent and if you check for
women it was highest which is close to
15 and above
cool
now we come to our first unemployment
category that is between the 1980 and
1990
so let's start with our
line chart so i'll first give the figure
size i'll say plt dot figure within
square brackets i'll say fig
size
equal to i'll give 15 comma five
now i'll say
sns
dot
line plot
and then i'll say
data equal to
employment
and since we want the data between 1980
and 1990 we need to subset
our data frame the original data frame
so for that i'm going to say
data equal to
unemployment and within
square brackets i'll give parenthesis
again say unemployment
dot
date
should be
greater than equal to
i'll pass in my date to be let's see
first of jan
1980
and then
i'll say
ambushant
i'll start another bracket i'll say
unemployment
dot
date
should be
less than equal to
let's say
first off december
1984.
so this is the time period that we are
looking at starting from 1980 till
1983.
now after that
we need to pass in the x-axis and the
y-axis so i'll say
x column or the x-axis to be a date
column and in the y-axis we'll have
let's say
the
unemployment rate for women
okay
next
let me run this and we'll see the output
there you go
so here you can see the
unemployment
rate for women between 1980 and 1984.
so if you see here
the unemployment rate for women peaked
between 1983
and
1984 so now we are going to analyze
this data specifically
so
let me just give a comment
say
unemployment
rate
of
women
between
10
1982
and
december 1983
all right
so i'll just copy this above and then we
will edit our
time
paste it here
let the figure size be the same
and then
my date should start from 1st of january
1982 because we want to focus
on the period that we saw peak
and
the next date
should be less than equal to
1st of jan
1984
[Music]
just everything remains the same maybe
you can add a color here so i can add
another parameter here let's say color
we want brown
you run it
now you can
see the
values here
and clearly there is a visible spike
of the unemployed
women during 1983 and 1984.
all right
similarly
we can check the unemployment rate of
men between
january 1982 and december 1983.
let me just
paste whatever i had copied
and here instead of
women will make it men
and the rest remains the same
another thing i wanted to show here is
now if you see this graph the labels on
the x-axis are present horizontally and
if you want you can rotate the x-axis
labels by using the
x-tix option or the parameter that we
have
so i'll say
plt dot x
takes
then i'll say
rotate it by let's say 30 degrees
okay
give a
semicolon
and we'll run it
okay it has thrown an error let's see
text object has no property rotations
so actually this should be rotation
we'll delete the s and run it there you
go
so here you can see
while most men lost their jobs
starting
you can say july
of 1982.
so the unemployment rate increased in
1982 for both men and women if you
compare both the graphs
so around july 1982
the unemployment rate increased
while men had the
highest unemployment rate which was
around 12.5 percent while women
it was around 10.5 percent
now the cell that you see here
will segregate the data into
different ages so we saw we have the
different
age
columns that is between 16 to 17 for
younger people
then we have the adults between 22 let's
say 34 and then you have
data for
35 to 44 as well as 55 and above
so
what we are doing here is we are
creating line plot for each of the
groups of ages
and we are trying to
print them and we have used
the labels as well
so let's run this and we'll see the
output
if i scroll down you can see the legend
here
the different colors that represent the
different age groups
now
overall if you see
the
there was some peak
after 1983 onwards
in young people
that again points out a fact that more
younger people that is below
19 years of age lost their jobs in
comparison to people above 20.
if you see these
blue and the orange line it represents
the younger population between 16 to 19
so they were the most affected during
the 1980s
all right
now let's move ahead and now we are
going to analyze
the unemployment during the great
recession of
2010
so i'll create a variable called
recession
equal to
i'll say
unemployment
and
within
square brackets i'll say
unemployment dot
date
to be
greater than equal to
say 1st of jan
2009 because that was the time when we
had the greater session
and then
i'll say
ampersand
i'll again use another
bracket and say unemployment
dot
date to be
less than or equal to
let's say
december
30
2014.
cool
this should be a hyphen here
okay
now
i'll say
recession
dot
tail
run it
you can see the bottom five rows from
the data set
and we have
values till
2014. all right
cool
so now let's visualize the data
that is the recession data
and the overall unemployment rate
so i'll say
plt dot
figure
and then i'll give my
figure
size
equal to 15 comma five
next i'll say
sns dot
line plot
and i'll say my data to be equal to
recession
comma my x
to be
date
and my y
to be
rate
column now let's run it
and you can see the
result here so between 2009 to 2015 you
can see there was a clear spike and the
unemployment rate in the united states
went
close to 11 percent
around 2010
that is mid of 2009 and 2010
now
we are going to
visualize the data individually for
men and women as well as for the
different age groups
so i'll just
paste my above cell here
and now let's change the y axis to
unread underscore
men
i'll say
let's say add a label called
men
colon
let's also
give the legend so that
men
displace
on the top right
so if i run it here you can see
we have the unemployment
graph
for
men
cool
now if you
see the
statistics for
recession
on
the unemployment for the unemployed
men during this specific period
we'll use describe function and run it
so here you can see
the values
so the average
unemployment rate
was
around 8.7 percent during this period
the maximum
was 12.3 percent if you see the graph
this is around 12.3 percent that's the
peak
and the minimum unemployment rate was
5.3 percent which is this
part
all right
and similarly we'll now check for
women
so i'll just copy this
and
paste it here
we'll edit the y-axis i'll say
women
and
i'll edit the label as women
let's run it
and you can see the output here
want you can add
a color
let's say
brown
you can now see the
unemployment rate of women during this
period between 2009 till 2015.
now again let's
use the describe function over the
column
unemployed
rate of women
so i'll just edit this to be women
you can see here the average
unemployment rate for women during this
period that is of the greater session
was seven point six nine percent
the maximum was nine point
four percent and the minimum was four
point nine percent or close to five
percent which is this value
cool the next cell as we did above we
are now categorizing
the unemployment rate based on each
group so starting from 16 till 55 and
above
let's run it
and you can see the output here
so the unemployment rate
touches around
35 percent you see here it was around 35
percent so the unemployment levels
touched
actually sky high
during 2010 if you see this this is
around 2010 it was around
35 percent for the eligible
youth
those were unemployed
and after that you have the second age
group which is between
18 to 19 who are the most affected
followed by
20 to 24
and then you have 25 to 34 and so on and
so forth
great coming to our final section where
we'll analyze the data around the kobit
19 so this is the beginning of 2020 when
the world was hit by
kobit 19 so i'm going to filter the data
so i'll create a variable called cobit
underscore 19 i'll use my
original data frame which is
unemployment
and then
i'll give square brackets
and within braces i'll say
unemployment
dot date to be
greater than equal to
it should be greater than equal to let's
say 1st of jan
2020
okay
now let's
print microwave 19 data set i'll see
kobe 19. head
so here you can see our data starts from
1st of jan 2020 then 2nd of january
third
so on and so forth
great
now here let's first analyze the
data for
unemployment rate for men
i'll just
copy one of the cells above and i'll
paste it and then we can edit it
let's say i'll copy this
and then
let me just paste it here
so let the figure size be 15 comma 5 and
data instead of recession we are going
to use covet 19.
okay
next my x column will be the same that
is date and my by column will have
unemployment rate of men
would be men and let's say
i'll have a color of let's say i'll use
cyan
and we'll give plt.legend
let's run it there you go
so if you see this graph clearly
around
march and april 2020 there was a huge
spike in the unemployment rates in the
united states
for men which crossed nearly
13 percent
and
around july late july and october
between late july and october it started
decreasing
so this was the time when
u.s was hit by
the corona virus wave
great
i'm going to use the describe function
again over the
unemployment rate of men so i'll say
kubit underscore 19
then i'll say
unread underscore
men dot
describe
if i run this
and scroll down you can see here
most men lost their jobs in
march 2020 with unemployment rates
peaking at around 13.3 percent
that you see in the graph here which is
the peak point is around 13.3 percent
okay
similarly let's do it for
women as well so i'll just copy this
code
and
paste it here
now instead of
unemployment rate for men we'll see
unemployment rate for women
and label would be women
we can use a color let's say
green
okay
let the legend be there
and we'll run it
now if you
look at this graph closely
what you see is there was a huge spike
again during
march and april 2020 when the cases
started rising in the united states and
for women it was around 15 percent
compared to men which had 13.3 percent
now if i
use the describe function
and replace this with
unemployment rate for women and run it
you see here the maximum value it's
touched was close to 16 percent which is
15.7 so this value is
15.7 and
the average
percent was
6.9 that is close to 7 percent of
unemployment throughout this period
all right
now the final cell we are again
segregating our data into different age
groups and we'll see
what age group was impacted the most
during the coronavirus pandemic
let's run it
okay now if i scroll down you see here
the orange line represents the
unemployment rate between 18 to 19 years
of age so during the corona virus
pandemic that is around
march and april 2020
this age group between 19 to 18 to 19
years of age were the most affected
that is
around
33 percent
after that we have the age group between
16 to 17 which is again over 30 percent
followed by
20 to
24
and then we have the other gauge groups
as well
so most women lost their jobs in march
of 2020 with unemployment rates speaking
15.7 percent that we saw just above
15.7 percent
so from the above data it is evident
that women were most affected by the
pandemic
so i hope
this demo was useful for you in creating
an analysis an exploratory analysis
using a time series data we saw
all our graphs based on date and time
and that brings us to the end of our
demo session
hope this video was useful and
informative if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you